you
[Music]
good morning Hank it's Monday December
12th one of the last days that I can
make meaningful revisions to Paper Towns
and you know how much I like to make
meaningful revisions honestly Hank I
would probably still be revising my
first book my great mini book it's
wonderful amazing if my second grade
teacher hadn't wrenched it from my hands
and insisted we get it bound Hank
today's video comes in three parts first
we're gonna see what it's like when I
punch my camera are you okay
I'm sorry I was just trying to do
something that Hank did because I
thought it would be funny I didn't know
that it was going to get out of control
like that second Hank the folks at
merriam-webster have announced the word
for 2007 and the word is woot now what
is kind of like an e Cummings poem in
that in order to fully appreciate it you
have to see it but it's a great word and
I'm happy to see that leet-speak has
come so far that it's now getting word
of the year type attention although I do
kind of Miss the old style elite speak
when we would you know develop
complicated and extensive vocabularies
in order to be able to talk about
different subjects with great nuance but
Hank as much as I do like woot I can't
help but feel that it wasn't the perfect
word of 2007 particularly since as far
as I'm concerned woot sort of hit its
peak in 2006 I feel like the word of
2007 should have been a word that was
invented in 2007 and so I wrote the
editors of merriam-webster a letter I'd
like to read it to you dear miss yours
Miriam and Webster today is a sad day
for the English language now
sad isn't the word I'm looking for today
is an unwanted listen all day two
teenagers playing Halo three online and
you will hear nary a word in fact the
young people of America are so bereft
that they will find it difficult to
summon any kind of leet speak whatsoever
today no noobs will be pwned hack sirs
won't be able to bring themselves to
steal wares or even to download prawn
indeed December 12th 2007 will be
forever remembered as the day the walls
died because the young people of America
are devastated that you picked as word
of the year for 2007 a word that apex in
2006 footnote apex I just made up that
word I am such a neologistic footnote I
also made up niala gist this tragedy is
compounded by the fact
there was a word available to you that
would have made the young people of
America
whoot from coast-to-coast I am referring
of course to nerdfighter nerdfighter
pones woot everyone knows that and if
you don't know what a nerdfighter is I
don't know how you wake up every morning
and call yourself a lexicographer ttys
John Green Hank just in case you and the
nerdfighters would also like to write
merriam-webster to express your
disappointment that they didn't pick the
word nerdfighter I've included their
contact information in the video info
part 3 do you think we should get a
puppy and if you do think we should get
a puppy what should we call it I already
suggested bubbles the nerdfighting puppy
but Sarah vetoed it Hank I hope the
secret project moving along and I'll see
you tomorrow
scavenger hunters the reason there
hasn't been a scavenger hunt clue in a
couple days is because we are preparing
for the big huge final scavenger hunt
and that will start soon